You have something i want
it will be mine
you must reunite it with its own kind where
the songs of eon's past tell of battles between
mandalore the great and an order of sorcerers
called jedi you expect me to search the galaxy and
deliver this creature to a race of enemy sorcerers
this is the way
you know this is no place for a
child i go he goes so i've heard
this is the way the mandalorian new season
streaming october 30th on disney plus
Welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new mandalorian season 2
trailer video this is the way they dropped a bunch
of new footage there's a bunch of easter eggs here
you probably already noticed so we'll break it
all down if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos i will be
doing episode videos for all the episodes during
season 2 and it's coming in a couple weeks i'll
just number these as we go along to stay organized
but it starts with the footage of moff gideon
highlighting the darksaber in his voiceover
talking about baby yoda belonging to him and
how the mandalorian can't comprehend what he has
you may think you know but you do not giancarlo
esposito talked a lot about maf gideon during
season 2 and learning more about his backstory
where he came from how he got the darksaber and
the lore of the darksaber along with the lore
of the mandalorian culture you can't really talk
about the history of the darksaber without talking
about the history of the mandalorians and we got a
little bit of that in some teasers during season 1
episode 8 when he was talking about each of their
backstories like he knows way more about all the
mains than they think that he knows we got all
the flashbacks to the death watch mandalorians
rescuing him as a child so it just sounds like
they're going to continue with that same style
of storytelling where something will happen
and it will cause him to flashback and remember
his training with the death watch mandalorians
the really cool connection there is that obviously
they were heavily featured during the clone wars
even john favreau himself on the mandalorian
played pre-vizsla during the clone wars episodes
and introduced the darksaber to the star wars
universe even though in the context of the history
and the lore is actually thousands of years old
and was built by the very first mandalorian to
ever become a jedi one of the other funny things
that giancarlo esposito talked about was how many
of these props of the darksaber the physical props
he actually broke when they were filming season
two episodes he joked that he'd been through about
three of them by the time they'd been halfway
through filming episodes so he didn't say who he
was fighting but because we have so much ahsoka
stuff coming during season two so much more jedi
and force lore coming it just sounds like it's
going to be a combination of a bunch of different
types of fight scenes like some sort of fight
with the mandalorian himself another fight with a
force sensitive user it could be with ahsoka it'd
be really badass to see him have a full-blown
lightsaber fight with her but i don't know how
big she's going to be during season 2 because
we don't see her in any of this new footage she
feels like the one thing they're trying to keep
secret but she's being played by rosario dawson
all this new fan art that people have been posting
seems like a really good approximation for what
she'll probably look like during the series we
have the footage of sasha banks character in the
hooded jedi looking robe in the other trailer when
they have the voiceover talking about him finding
enemy sorcerers quote unquote where am i supposed
to find them the armor just tells them that's what
you're supposed to determine yourself you have to
just go out and look for them you have to remember
that most of the jedi that survived the purge
or former jedi depending on how you want to talk
about them or force sensitive people that didn't
have jedi training is that most of the force
sensitive people that were rounded up later became
part of his inquisitor core they actually covered
that during star wars rebels or they just went to
ground and just show up at various points through
star wars lauren history one of the few examples
of that obviously obi-wan kenobi we'll learn more
about what's going on with him during the obi-wan
kenobi series i'll mention that at the end of this
video too because ewan mcgregor was talking about
when they're going to be filming that and what the
series is going to be like but we get some more
footage of those thai outlanders with the folding
wings taking off from what seems like navarro
just from the looks of the planet it's hard to
tell but there's a lot of footage in this trailer
that all seems like it's from the same episode on
this same planet there's a brand new scene
of the mandalorian cara dune and grief karga
on what looks like an imperial ship or inside
an imperial base i'm assuming that it might be
connected to the footage of him escaping from this
base later just from that imperial signature grey
metal behind them there's more footage of dinjaran
taking off with his jet pack from the imperial
base over this lava flow all the lava here with
the imperial base also kind of reminds you of
mustafar so that might be some of the easter eggs
they're going for during this particular episode
obviously because in this other thai outlander
shot you see this giant lava burst after the
blaster shots land behind them it just seems like
this is all connected in part of the same episode
them trying to infiltrate this imperial base for
some reason either because they're on a bounty
or they're trying to steal something or they're
trying to rescue baby yoda this is also probably
from the same scene with the stormtroopers
running down that same looking hallway and
the scene of all the stormtroopers on the speeder
bikes later that are taking off just because the
terrain looks very similar there's another new
scene of cara dune in the middle of a fight in a
very jabba's palace looking structure just look
at the architecture of the doorways behind her
this might also be part of the tatooine episode
that they're doing during season two or however
many tatooine episodes we already got a bunch of
tatooine footage with the tuscan raider in the
last trailer with a speeder bike in the promise
of all the boba fett easter eggs that they've
been teasing obviously we also haven't seen boba
fett at least that we know of during any of this
trailer footage yet timothy oliphant's character
is supposedly also going to show up during these
tatooine episodes however many they wind up being
most of the boba fett seems like it's going to be
pretty light during season 2 though and he'll
be a much bigger character during season 3.
this new scene of grieve karga seems like he's
operating the gun turret inside the razor crest
it seems like a reference to star wars a
new hope with luke skywalker and han solo
most of the references they've been pulling so far
especially as of season 1 were for the original
trilogy of movies but they also pulled a bunch
of clone wars easter eggs just because they're
so heavy on the mandalorians during the clone wars
but because of when this is all happening in the
timeline you also get a lot of prequel easter eggs
too so i would expect to see more prequel easter
eggs just popping up throughout the episodes this
scene of him landing amidst all the stormtroopers
that he looks like he just can't also seems
like it's happening from that same episode
at the imperial base like he trashes all these
imperials and i think it's safe to assume that
they are probably on maf gideon's payroll pretty
much anybody imperial or any imperial assets in
this part of space seems like it's controlled by
moff gideon when jean carlo esposito was teasing
some of moff gideon's other big toys and assets
that he has he made references to having a much
much bigger ship i think that's just the teaser
that he might wind up having an imperial star
destroyer classic design of course because
we're talking about original trilogy easter eggs
obviously there's still a thousand questions
that everyone has about the series we want to
know what's going on with ahsoka and with
sasha banks character just because of the
way they connected them through the last big
trailer the voice over talking about jedi while
they show you sasha bank's character
and an order of sorceress called jedi
there were a lot of people that thought
that just because of the way sasha banks
looks kind of similar to what you would assume
a live-action version of sabine might look like
and there been rumors about them doing live-action
sabine that might be who she's playing but i think
that's a bit of a long shot i think if we see ezra
bridger or we see sabine they would show up on a
separate tv series that focuses more on the rebels
characters like there is rumors about them doing
a live-action ahsoka tv series in the future
and if you didn't see the news disney actually
just announced that they're actually refocusing
their entire core business of movies and tv shows
on streaming and disney plus like they're still
going to release movies in movie theaters like you
would expect them to but most of the time now all
the development of their big projects is mostly
focused on disney plus so it just sounds like
they're doubling down on the big budget really
big splashy content for streaming that's been
one of the biggest complaints about disney plus
so far is that all they really have in terms of
huge content right now is the mandalorian season
one it has been pretty dry since that ended
we do have all the marvel disney plus stuff
coming up that's in the pipeline but it takes
them a while to get those episodes out so the
avengers Wandavision episodes are supposed to
premiere after the mandalorian season two episodes
and this is the schedule of all the mandalorian
season two episodes they start october 30th and
they do one episode per week all the way up to
december 18th so pretty safe bet that the
wandavision episodes will start premiering sometime
during either like that last week or two of the
mandalorian episodes if they overlap just a little
bit but they could always wait till after all the
mandalorian episodes are done and just premiere
it during christmas week 2020 may have been a crap
year but i think 2021 will be a little more solid
in terms of content that big studios are releasing
not just marvel but all the big studios obviously
all this trailer footage is only a fraction of the
stuff that they're doing during the mandalorian
season two though so everybody let me know in the
comments what other big stuff you hope that they
do during season two i've already done a couple
videos about the mandalorian season three they've
already talked about a bunch of the big spin-offs
that they're doing for the most part the show
is just going to continue for as long as the
characters the actors want to keep doing the show
so it sounds like they'll try to get at least five
seasons under their belt but by the time we get
towards those later seasons they'll have other
mandalorian spin-off shows while the obi-wan show
will have the other rumored shows that they've
been working on inside the star wars universe
i'll do more bonus videos for the mandalorian
as we get a little bit closer but leave all your
requests in the comments below while you wait
for everything click here for that brand new
avengers wandavision trailer and click here for
the boys season 3 trailer thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe this is the way!